turning overseas there is a new twist in
the investigation into the assassination
of haiti's president cbs news has
learned a haitian american arrested in
the killing
had worked as a confidential informant
to the dea
during last week's attack at the
president's home gunmen can be heard
announcing themselves as dea agents
but the dea says the gunmen were not
acting on its behalf
mololanki is in haiti that's the capital
port-au-prince where there's
rising fear mola good morning to you
well good morning haiti is a country on
edge this morning as a political vacuum
threatens to destabilize an already
unstable nation
haitians we spoke to say everyone is
scared no one feels safe
outside the u.s embassy in
port-au-prince a mad rush to leave and
immigrate to the u.s
chance of joe biden rang through the
crowd most holding their passports
we spoke to minos mistador a mother from
miami desperate to get her 14 year old
son to america
she says her ex-husband was a police
officer killed here in march
there's a lot of violence here even the
president isn't safe here
you're trying to get your son off
guidance guys why because in security i
got only one son
so i don't want one place where they
kidnap him or they kill him
anything could be happening to him we
went and saw the remains of one building
at the center of the investigation into
president jovanelle mohis
assassination you can still see the
bullet holes
this is where the alleged gunman
exchanged fire with police
after an intense manhunt just down the
street from where president moyes was
shot and killed in his private home
less than a mile away outside the
president's compound security forces in
camo protected the perimeter
this is as far as we could get
investigators still don't know how the
assassins got into the president's
compound and aren't ruling anything out
including the possibility of inside help
since none of the president's guards
were hurt
investigators remain focused on u.s
resident christian cenon a
self-proclaimed doctor who had once
filed for bankruptcy and was living in
florida
the haitian national police chief
alleges senon was in contact with a
florida-based security firm called ctu
security that he says recruited
at least some of the 26 colombians
involved in the attack
and said cenon planned to take over as
president himself
most suspects were arrested including
two haitian americans who said they were
hired as translators
the doj says it will investigate to see
if any u.s laws were broken
as president biden weighs whether to
send in u.s troops
haiti's political leaders need to come
together for the good of their country
we see here at the president's compound
where he was assassinated security
still here on guard we reached out to
ctu security that firm in florida
we have not heard back from them should
mention that cenon was arrested
here in haiti but those who knew him
well told the associated press
they believe that he was duped by the
real masterminds of this assassination
anthony reporting from haiti thank you
mola